yesterday something happened something I
changed my life
tumblr follow me on Twitter
why why does tumblr follow me all these
questions
let's find out
now I've never actually been to tumblr
so I don't really know what to expect
here's one blog called weird stock
photography I don't see anything weird
with that oh now I see it
necrophilia Oh Santa is injecting snow
in his system that's how he lives so
long she gonna shoot that melon cuz
that's just [ __ ] up that one got me
alright you did a good job
tumblr moving on but gets men nuts so
this is basically a Photoshop tumblr
blog there seems to be a lot of these
where basically they replace an object
in a picture with another object here's
the skateboard is a baguette here the
lead is a baguette those are youtubers
right they have baguettes in their hands
moving on to ugly Renaissance babies now
I have this theory that all kids are
babies now wait what the [ __ ] did I just
say I have a theory that all kids are
ugly what I meant to say that's not even
a baby that is an extremely ugly baby
I'm not gonna lie look that is a lot of
Chin's for a baby sorry I have I have
this thing that if I see too many Chin's
I gotta do this
you
okay oh man that looks beautiful
that kid is no longer ugly you're
welcome tumblr I mean they're ugly but
they're not like holy [ __ ] they're ugly
oh my god
that's the face you make when you have
to grab that kind of baby it's like your
friend your friends is like here hold my
baby and you're just like okay I won't
see baby another one guys with Zoe's
eyes that's that's the fat guy in all
the marijuana movies Stephen Colbert
Conan Andy I would rate that one zero
out of Zehra that was piece of [ __ ]
brides throwing cats.com this one even
bought its own domain and I mean these
photo shops are pretty [ __ ] I'm not
gonna lie like get out of here
there's not even a you're not they're
not even blending the blur all right you
know what I'm gonna do better
look this is awful see this is a good
picture to pick because we can easily
take away the flowers by just sampling
boom it's gone now let's just add the
cat should be easy to crop out there we
go give it a little bit of coloring a
little bit of motion blur and there you
go a ten times better picture in like
what two minutes
thank you very much you piece of [ __ ]
vlog maybe I'll buy my own domain okay
so this is a guy who takes pictures of
himself in front of people making out
okay that's kind of awesome I mean
everyone needs a hobby and this guy
clearly found his I mean this this is
pretty good this is pretty original I
like this men taking up too much space
on the train a classic among public
assertions of privilege I hope this is a
parody he's not even sitting next to him
what's the big [ __ ] deal
okay that guy's a jackass the guy's
clearly drunk and sleeping but the thing
is there's digit just ask him to move
don't be such a [ __ ] [ __ ] and make a
blog about it Jesus Christ
exploding actresses dot tumblr.com okay
Hey oh [ __ ]
is that when she fell oh yeah that's
when she fell Oh see this takes effort
and talent this I can appreciate why
this blog exists I don't know
but am i thankful absolutely shaking
food gypsum lurk on
this is very satisfying sketchy bunnies
oh my god I hate sketchy bunnies oh my
god Jesus Christ oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh yeah that's that's appropriate
face oh my god
why why pork balls replace with cats
well I hope they're better Photoshop
than the other one oh it's the same
person - listen mate if you make if you
do this out of livin you got to become
less shitty at it I don't know what to
tell you
alright I'm gonna give you some some
free premiums here microphones replaced
with Obama ceiling fans replaced with a
with with George Lucas steering wheels
replaced with Nicolas Cage there you go
there that's three way better options
just like that there you go
Nicolas Cage replaced with steering
wheels about ten times better
thank you very very much I might start
this blog and I think it might be
something that you know replaces you
know I don't think it will be a huge
success right away but I think
eventually in my take over my youtube
channel
actresses without teeth hey didn't
didn't I Photoshop this Pokemon Nick
Cage every Pokemon including Darth Vader
into Nicolas Cage
when people think I have too much spare
time all right last one good night to
you oh it's eating backwards yeah oh my
god Kirby what the [ __ ]
this is oddly satisfying to look at well
I guess it's the new diet what's making
happen I think I get a tumblr you know
all these years all these years tumblr I
spent being confused no no no why you
hate me
and what I've done against you but it
seems like now finally we found a love a
common ground but you know what
it's too late [ __ ] so sorry I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry
please don't unfollow me please don't
please please please alright thank you
for watching this video I hope you
enjoyed it if you did leave it a thumbs
up or subscribe to become a breath today
and I will see you in the next video and
as always stay awesome breasts am i a
dog I am a Shetland Sheepdog strong
Barker hey I can roll with that